nimmt man breakfast wörtlich dann kann
das sonntagsfrühstück schon mal als
schlacht mit ball und säge enden
so geschehen in der fotoserie breakfast
was übersetzt soviel wie schnell
zerbrechen bedeutet es sind die bilder
der spanischen fotografen des addo mega
die nahrungsmittel und
alltagsgegenstände zweckentfremdet in
szene setzt
ich würde meine arbeit mit drei worten
beschreiben
eigenwillig detailliert und absurd
[Musik]
herauskommen so reale kompositionen wie
ein frühstücksei das mit scharfer
munition beschossen wird
oder pancakes die anstatt in der pfanne
mit dem bügeleisen gebraten werden
als kreativdirektorin fotografiert es
adonia heute für eine shopping mall in
madrid vier motive sollen auf plakaten
und in social media kanälen auf die
modegeschäfte und die gastronomische
auswahl aufmerksam machen
von klassischer food fotografie hebt
sich tessa doni gab dabei ganz bewusst
ab ok setz dich aufrecht da hin und
zeigt dass du dich über den schuh und
den hot dog freust was man bei mir in
der regel sieht ist essen das ein wenig
deplatziert wirkt in einer art die man
so noch nicht gesehen hat aus dem
kontext google und übertrieben
inszeniert hier haben wir ein model mode
und eine aktion die spielerisch mit
essen umgeht
während ihres kunststudiums entdecktes
adonia ihre leidenschaft für fotografie
und film 2015 gründet sie ihre eigene
agentur
sie dreht werbe spots und produziert
fotoserien für zeitschriften
ihr markenzeichen pastellfarben und
reduzierte bildkompositionen ihr
spezialgebiet essen mal exzentrisch mal
provokant inszeniert die größte
herausforderung alles muss frist und
perfekt aussehen
während das model für das zweite foto
gestylt wird ist tessa dorniger bereits
unterwegs
das essbare requisit fehlt noch für ihr
nächstes motiv benötigt sie einen
perfekt gebratenes spiegelei mangels
kochzeile im fotostudio besorgt sie es
kurzerhand im café nebenan spiegeleier
sind empfindlich da sich schnell trocken
werden
hier kann ich sie gleich mitnehmen ich
denke ich kann maximal eine stunde mit
ihnen arbeiten
wer nicht muss ich noch mal hierher
kommen es geht eben nichts über
improvisationstalent
[Musik]
die eier habe ich hoffentlich fallen sie
mir unterwegs nicht runter
[Musik]
zurück im studio setzt hathor dorniger
das spiegelei umgehend in szene
hauptaugenmerk liegt auf dem eigelb das
mit chirurgischer präzision angepasst
wird
[Musik]
das perfekte ei für das foto ist eines
das glänzt eine schöne farbe hat und
nicht angebrannt ist natürlich
bearbeiten wir die bilder später noch
aber es gilt je mehr glanz und fülle
desto besser nur der sandwich zu
fotografieren
das wäre zu einfach stattdessen wird das
eigene zum nagellack umfunktioniert denn
nur ungewöhnliche geschichten
garantieren aufmerksamkeit ästhetisch
schöne bilder gibt es wie sand am meer
das internet ist voll davon jeder hat
heutzutage ein smartphone und hat fotos
es ist viel komplizierter geworden eine
witzige geschichte zu erzählen und sich
abzuheben
egal ob frühstück mittag- oder
abendessen
auch die heutigen fotos von tessa
dorniger machen appetit auf mehr
[Musik]